this is it guys there are nutritious
garbage there's a floors and also a mint
Frappuccino you know what this means
we're gonna do a taste test are you at
Starbucks right now we've got a few new
summer during the floors one has been in
Starbucks before but we've got you the
new frappuccinos the middle of green
frappuccinos we guys wondered about
happy users this wealth chocolate has
caffeine without coffee this we're going
to go a writer you're safe that's always
the star wasn't North Irish email
this woman is the premium property nope
this one doesn't have coffee in it give
it a little link
it's having light this is so good
my accomplice hi I'm the guard to us
and this one stupid one we're out the
cream this has a more popular to it
I prefer cross-eyed BBC
oh my god is it good if I thought I died
on this one
I'm definitely gentlemen Club I try them
both the same time
now we're gonna try is the grande min
smokeless cream Frappuccino and the
Grande tonight local from Kris crazy
oh my gosh that was brick
this is my favorite I love miss this has
not as much coffee in it or no coffee
rather she said how to compete
[Music]
I think I like this one better
I'm not sure what it is maybe it's
combinations of the coffee and a dark
chocolate segment but I like the cream
of Wands better I say my favorite out of
all four he drinks is probably the words
been spirited Northrup genomes along
with the coffee
oh yeah oh my god delicious
and
things like a campfire on a warm summer
camp naive it's a big pop of mine that
does it I didn't give you a quick little
taste test to do this all they had me
drink out for though I'm here in New
York for a while actually
so there's a nice little you know on the
beach oh my god laughs for drinking I
have a problem
somebody cool I haven't actually tried
this another trying to find a different
choice because I drink black combination
I'm on the Starbucks in partners
eligibility tree and this is going to be
something that I need to get them
through my guys try it
[Music]
whoa whoo oink-cool times have a much
deeper tape because they feel like gates
in terms of just sitting there brewing
themselves for over 24 hours and then
then trust me came to it I'm not sure if
I like domination of the course notes
with the cool group one of my favorite
drinks is coconut mocha macchiato the
kind of person he probably am not a huge
fan of the cool group I actually prefer
just the regular ice coffee
but usually what I'll do because I get
like just a coffee shop wrestle with
water and I think you're a drag or
coffee all day but I really go let me
know who I'd try these and let me know
what you guys think I feel like a lot of
you are few strands of uniform
Frappuccino in Japan so things for
nothing
I'll see you guys later
[Music]
you